you know bootleg Capcom there ain't no
kickin it right now smokers club my dude
absol Feeny he's almost our brother
brother hey I'm good man toy life all
right no pressure just work overtime
some like so you know there's a bad
night trying to do lucky so let's talk
about oh I've never noticed this tattoo
this from the Pete Rock House that's why
I never understood mr. soldier boy
salsify Ram I remember to join on there
with Mathematica was corrupt
yeah yeah we had a lot of letter classic
why'd you get that and I'm so brother
number two okay so I was only right that
uh you know tell you how Mr soul brother
number I do appreciate that about you I
thought I got everybody in T de you just
the collaborations that you do and just
you when you when you hear your music
you know that you have like some real
thorough ass hip-hop tastes you know
what I'm saying yeah when I grew up in
the record shop so you know I think that
has that might have a lot to do with it
and any of a diverse
catalog yeah you definitely do man talk
about some of your influences like album
eyes like of course you got that on your
arm but but what it was what are some
other early albums it then as a kid
maybe shaped you as an artist that you
are today oh yeah like you know like the
first like out probably like like went
crazy about was twisters adrenaline yeah
that's that's a good [__] right there
you know I forgot a crucial confidence
out of mission yo showdown hey Andy
about and then you know yeah thing like
that guy who's like cannabis and you
know came around I really I think my
favorite album is jay-z's reasonable
doubt okay so I mean I think that
however was probably like mom that's
dope like you down datian yeah you just
and it's funny because just the albums
that your name or just kind of all over
the place musically you know
that's dope man um how is a tour with
Joey badass been I know you guys share a
lot of the same fan base you know he's
from from the East Coast from the West
code word how was a house have been
creatively on the bus with you know two
great MCS yeah that's my guy man really
my guy man the whole program manner that
they're very intelligent young guys you
know we've been friends you know before
this tour so there's real fun to just
you know just sit down and you know
we're sharing books and you know share
night is you know it's just very cool
that's dope man
that's super dope you've been on to to
double XL covers this year yeah that's
crazy man yeah how is going to change
the profile when you walk down the
street I'm trying to stay on the bus
she's like I'm on the bus I don't want
to deal with none of that [__] yeah I
mean well you know not nothing ain't
trying to do driving me know oh I
definitely don't like to hold up traffic
that's crazy though like not a lot of
people can say that I'm seriously twice
in a year on the cover I know that you
had like spoken out about how double-xl
had positioned the last cover well
you're like I think you'd said you go do
that [__] again I believe black hippy or
some [__] right left me
I'm glad you asked I mean hope that was
him that wasn't exactly directed at
double-xl hello everybody right that's
everybody that's this that was for all
blogs or social media or all media
outlets a lot of them are printing it
like that and you know that's just not
what that's not the name of the group no
I feel you it's I think I think it's a
gift in a curse when you have someone
like Kendrick as big as he is I mean
he's on the cover of GQ cover of GQ the
new cover he's on is exactly anything
he's demand like for sure like I
wouldn't even be mad like you know like
if they had his name like super big and
like they just put our names under his
roof right I won't even be mad at that
but then I'm like looking at the cover
and then I see like you know it's
definitely absolutely no disrespect I
see my chance the rapper's name like one
yeah you don't see how close-knit but
but good so how come you don't see like
schoolboy q Jay right yeah no Jay right
you know I mean you know you know
chances are very good friend of mine but
it's just kind of like I don't
understand how bacon
yeah I mean it's like it's almost like I
feel like even watching interviews like
with everyone besides Kendrick it's like
it always Kendra always has to come up
and it's cool because he's put he's put
the crew on that on that on that
pedestal saw is all this oh well
deserved but I also think I think as
opposed to other movements in the past
to where one guy really took off and the
other guys worked work maybe not as
haven't you
so of course you of schoolboy q and
j-rock all are like run incredible
[__] or something you know so I guess
I guess I did it it yeah yeah I'm gonna
focus be there forever forgiveness
that's pretty much that's one of the
cornerstones it out just it was just
about progression
not just my just not my gosh power
regression as a team yeah